الرئيس الامريكي السابق المدعي العام في
منهات
بالتدخل في انتخابات رئاسيه حيث اتهمت مده
عام من هاتم بخلق القانون باستخدام ما
اسماء شهاده مشوهه من محامي ترامب السابق
مايكل كوهين الذي مثل الاسبوع الماضي امام
هيئه المحلفين الكبرى في التحقيق حول
مزاعم عن دفع ترامب مبلغ من المال لاسكات
سيده خلال حملته
الانتخابيه عام 2016
بجانبها قالت محاميه الرئيس الامريكي
السابق الينا هابا ان ادعاءه الاخير بشان
اعتقاله ليس تكهنا واضافتها لشبكه سي ان
الامريكيه بانه على علم بتسريبات من مكتب
المدعي العام بشان مزاعم التقارير الماليه
الاحتياليه من قبل منظمه ترامب قائله انها
سعيده بحديث رفض عن الامر لانه اذا كان
ذلك صحيحا فعليا فعليه ان يستبرقه على حد
تعبيرها
ومع اثاره رمب الامكانيه اعتقالها
المحتمله يبدو انه بدا حملته الرئاسيه
مبكرا بشكل موسع في مواجهه خصومه فبحسب
صحيفه بوليتيكو الامريكيه فان ترامب حول
لائحه الاتهام وشيكا الى اختبار حقيقي
لاعضاء حزبه لاسيما مع خصومه المحتملين في
انتخابات
2024 فباتت القضيه اما الدفاع عنه او وصف
من يقف عكس ذلك
بالمتعاطف مع اليسار بالطبع في اشاره الى
الديمقراطيين الذين قالوا انه لا احد فوق
القانون حيث اتهموا ترامب باذكاء
الانقسامات السياسيه سرعان ما التقط زعماء
حزب ترامب الخيط ودفعوا عنه فرغم انتقادات
وجهها لترامب منذ ايام بسبب هجوم
الكابيتال وقف نائب الرئيس الامريكي
السابق مايك بينس بالاضافه لزعيم
الجمهوريين في الكونجرس كيفن ارثي وقفاه
ضد اي محاكمه جنائيه لترامب وبحسب الصحيفه
فان ترامب اكبر المستفيدين من توقيت اثاره
الازمه سياسيا فهي بمثابه بدايه حقيقيه
للانتخابات ازاحه خصومه الديمقراطيين او
حتى من داخل حزبه في اشاره الى حاكم
فلوريدا روند سنتيس الذي فضل الصمت تجاه
مزاعم ترامب الاخيره
الى هنا من واشنطن المراسل العربيه حسين
الطوط اهلا بك حسين بدايه هل هناك اي
مؤشرات تؤكد او تنفي امكانيه اعتقال
الرئيس الامريكي السابق فهمت غدا
تحيه لك ابراهيم اليوم من المنتظر ان يمثل
امام هيئه المحلفين الكبرى في نيويورك
المحامي روبرتيه وهو كان
محاميا وايضا مستشارا قانونيا لمحامي
ترامب السابق مايكل
حسب ما علمنا ابلغ محاميه ترامب بان لديه
معلومات قد كل ما قاله كاهن وقد يبرئ تراب
من هذه القضيه طبعا اذا تم ذلك بالفعل فمن
المستبعد ان يتم توجيه تهم للترامب من
المستبعد ان يتم اعتقاله غدا كما هو متوقع
كما توقعت نفسه ولكن اذا لم يستطع تقديم
ادله على ذلك فمن المحتمل ان يكون هناك
اجراء اجراء تقديم الاتهام او توجيه
الاتهام ترامب بطبيعه الحال المدعي العام
طلب من كوهن ان يكون حاضرا ومستعدا ليضحض
ويقدم نقض شهاده نقد لكاستي
مثله امام الهيئه كما هو متوقع اليوم
الانظار الان
تتجه نحو ما سيقوله روبرت كاستيو وماذا
سيفعله وماذا سيقدمه لهيئه الكبرى في
نيويورك لنعرف بالفعل ماذا سيجري ردود
الفعل السياسيه حتى الساعه خصوصا داخل حزب
الجمهوري على كل ما يحدث حسين لو تجبلها
لنا
بشكل عام اذا استثنينا
رونددسماه الصمت جميع الجمهوريين دافعوا
عن ترامب وحتى ان قبل مكارتي رئيس مجلس
النواب في الولايات المتحده طالب او قال
انه سيوجه اللجان واللجان الفرعيه ذات
الصله بالتحقيق ما اذا كانت هناك اموال في
دلاليه قد استخدمت في هذا التحقيق
حسب قوله لتقويه الديمقراطيه الجمهوريون
واضحون انهم يدافعون عن ترامب طبعا معظمهم
رفض التظاهر ان هذا امر لا يستدعي التظاهر
رغم انهم قالوا ان التظاهر حق في الدستور
ولكنهم قالوا انه لا يجب ان يكون هناك
تظاهرات اما عن الجانب الديمقراطي بطبيعه
الحال اللي
السيناتور الديمقراطيه قالت انه هذا ايضا
يجب ان لا يتم التظاهر من اجله بالنسبه
لهذا الاحتجاج حتى هناك اخر قال بان لا
احد فوق القانون ولذلك هناك جدل كبير الان
في الكونغرس الامريكي بين الحزب الجمهوري
والديمقراطي الحزب الديمقراطي حول هذا
شكرا جزيلا لك حسين مراسل العربيه كنت
معنا مباشره من واشنطن